none of this research shows that vaping
is safe and it doesn't rule out the
possibility of negative health effects
that haven't been found yet but in
public policy the most important
question is instead of what in real life
there are no Solutions only trade-offs
there's overwhelming evidence that if
the alternative vaping and cigarette
smoking vaping represents a huge
Improvement for public health government
officials generally fail to reason in
these terms they tax ban and regulate as
if their policies exist in a vacuum
setting statistically dubious studies to
support their preconceived policies